your participation and losses in world
war one is memorialized in two important
ways at Woolsey Hall and in the
courtyard area between the by Nicki and
Woolsey Hall in Memorial Hall which is
the outer area as you enter either the
university commons or Woolsey Hall has
the names of the war dead inscribed and
there are two hundred and twenty four
names there for those that perished in
world war one that was done not long
after the war ended but through the 20s
the Alumni wanted to do more and to
create a more imposing memorial just for
world war one and so they raised money
to put what really became the largest
World War 1 memorial certainly in the
United States that was built it was
completed in 1927 and it the main part
of it is a huge colonnade which was
built on the side of the university
dining hall some people think that's of
the dining hall always look but it
actually is in addition and across the
top are engraved in the names of the
principal battles of World War one but
more importantly coming down the plaza
is a large Cenotaph or empty tomb which
represents the war dead of Yale and it
has beautiful statuary embellishments of
the symbols of war and peace and the
inscription on the front is a variant of
Abraham Lincoln's Gettysburg Address
every year the veterans day services are
held on the plaza in front of the
Cenotaph
you